it's one of the main priority is decided
by EU leaders when they fix the
directions for the next five years build
a European energy union it's crucial for
the economy the Europe security and to
fight climate change and effective
original can fundamentally improve the
situation in Europe by ensuring cheap
sustainable and secure energy for home
state companies and citizens
geopolitical events play a key role in
energy security in addition to the
ongoing tensions between Russia and
Ukraine persistently low oil prices and
new perspectives open up by the Iranian
nuclear deal are also impacting global
energy markets more than half of our
energy consumption is imported discussed
US 1 billion a day this means that we
have to take measures especially in the
current geopolitical context to first of
all solve some of the problems in our
infrastructure but also to reduce our
external dependence especially for those
countries who are dependent on a single
supplier pooling energy resources across
the EU is another way to ensure energy
security but in order to achieve this
renovation and better interconnections
of electricity grids and gas pipelines
are needed so that energy surfaces in
one member state can be easily channeled
to another member state with a shortage
yes location a hit before only from
Nissan zdenka das Khalifa bin
uncertainty McLeish artinfo Bassam about
rivers flow yet still pay homage to
wanted to type this out Christopher the
horses at cinda's other starting over
like bugs and fear gas pipelines the
leaders of France Spain and Portugal
agreed in Madrid to double the
electricity interconnection capacity
between their three countries and to
start a major gas project proyecto como
la integración europea near integr are y
conectar meanwhile in the east northern
corner lithuania open its own liquefied
natural gas floating terminal labeled
independence well this terminal the
Baltic state not only reduces its
previously 100% dependency on Russia but
it can also supply its neighbors for
example Poland achieving 10%
interconnection is the goal proposed by
the European Commission in its energy
union plan it will require serious
investment it is estimated that in the
next two decades we will need two
hundred billions a year to upgrade our
current system not only to meet future
demand but simply also to replace the
existing infrastructure what we need to
do is to give a vision to that a
direction to that so that the Member
States the market players make the right
investments investments which in turn
will not only generate economic growth
and more jobs in the energy sector but
also make energy cheaper this is crucial
for Europe's competitiveness at times
where energy bills are thirty percent
less in the u.s. than in Europe cleaner
energy is a very important dimension of
Europe's energy Union plan the UN
climate change conference the cop21 in
Paris provides a clear momentum for a
big push for more energy efficiency and
a new generation of renewables the EU is
at the forefront of the decarbonisation
effort and it wants other countries to
follow
jajaja mexia know of the bhakti la
première second Commission lack of the
very short email with a target of forty
percent cuts in greenhouse gas emissions
by 2030 the EU leads the world's fight
against climate change the energy union
is the main driving force to reach that
target